DOWN HERE THIS MORNING.
JESSE?
>> Jesse: THANKS, CASEY.
ALL RIGHT, KIMBERLY JUST SO
YOU KNOW ANOTHER HORRIBLE
TRAGEDY ON A FRIDAY IN THIS
COUNTRY IT SEEMS LIKE ALMOST
ONCE A MONTH AT THIS POINT.
WHAT JUMPS OUT AT YOU AFTER
YOU HEAR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS?
ANYTHING SPECIFIC AND
ANYTHING THAT YOU CAN
REFLECT ON FOR THE AUDIENCE?
>> Kimberly: YEAH, WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT, CAN YOU FEEL
IT, RIGHT?
IT'S HEAVY.
YOU HATE TO REPORT ON A
STORY LIKE THIS FAMILY
MEMBERS.
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING.
INCLUDING PARENTS OF EVEN
THE SHOOTER IN TERMS OF WHAT
HAPPENED, WHAT WENT WRONG.
PEOPLE THINKING TO
THEMSELVES A SENSE OF GUILT
AND RESPONSIBILITY.
WHAT COULD I HAVE DONE TO
PREVENT SOMETHING, YOU KNOW,
LIKE THIS.
THE NUMBER OF CASUALTIES IS
HEART-BREAKING.
THOSE INJURED AND THOUGHTS
AND PRAYERS TO THE FAMILIES
AND ALSO TO THE HOSPITALS,
YOU KNOW, WORKERS, THE
NURSES, THE DOCTORS.
EVERYBODY WHO MOVED IN TO
TRY TO SAVE LIVES SO THAT
THERE WEREN'T EVEN MORE
FATALITIES.
I KNOW IN TERMS OF THE
INVESTIGATION THEY REALLY DO
HAVE TO DO A DEEP DIVE INTO
HIS SOCIAL MEDIA, INTO THINK
KIND OF MOTIVE, MENTAL
STATE.
BUT, ALSO IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE THAT HE COMMUNICATED
WITH?
THEY WERE ALSO GOING TO BE
QUESTIONING A COUPLE OTHER
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE CONCERNED AND THEY
SET UP A VERY LARGE
PERIMETER IN CASE THERE ARE
ANY EXPLOSIVE DEVICES THAT
HAD BEEN SECLUDED AROUND THE
AREA OF THE PROPERTY OR
SCHOOL THAT COULD STILL
CAUSE HARM.
RIGHT AWAY YOU GOING TO BE
WANTING TO QUESTION THIS
INDIVIDUAL TO DETERMINE THAT
THERE IS NO FURTHER LOSS OF
LIFE OR CASUALTY IN A
SITUATION LIKE THIS.
AND YOU SEE KIND OF THE
ELEVATION SHOTS THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO THAT AND REALLY
CHECK THE AREA TO MAKE SURE
THERE ISN'T ANYTHING ELSE
THAT DOESN'T GO UNDETECTED.
>> Jesse: HE WAS SUPPOSED TO
TAKE HIS LIFE.
DID HE NOT TAKE HIS OWN LIFE
AND HE IS IN CRITICAL
CONDITION.
SO, LAW ENFORCEMENT, GREG,
GOING TO BE ABLE TO
INTERROGATE HIM PRETTY
THOROUGHLY.
>> YEAH.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR FROM
HIM.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WE DID THIS
FUN STORY FOR THE LAST
COUPLE DAYS THE LAUREL AND
YANNY THING.
I CAN'T HELP BUT SEE EVERY
NEWS STORY THROUGH THAT
PRISM.
EVERYBODY GOES INTO THEIR
SEPARATE SIDES.
IT'S EITHER LAUREL, WHICH IS
WE NEED MORE ARMED SECURITY
OR IT'S YANNY, THERE ARE TOO
MANY GUNS.
AND IT'S TOO MANY GUNS
VERSUS NOT ENOUGH ONLY WAY
TO GET THROUGH THIS STUFF
AND MOVE BEYOND IT IS GET
OUT OF THIS PRISON OF TWO
IDEAS.
AND ACTUALLY SEEK A
COMPROMISE FROM BOTH SIDES
TO LOOK AT OKAY, WHAT
EFFECTIVE GUN CONTROL
MEASURE WOULD WORK?
I ALWAYS TALK ABOUT A SYSTEM
THAT TAGS CERTAIN PEOPLE
CONSIDERED TO BE HIGH RISK
BY TEACHERS AND AUTHORITIES.
A CIVIL COURT THAT TAGS THIS
PERSON SO THEY CAN'T HAVE
GUNS.
THE PROBLEM IS WITH THIS GUY
HE GOT THE GUNS FROM HIS
PARENTS.
SO HE GETS THROUGH.
SO THE OTHER THING THEN IS
TO TRAIN MORE ARMED
PERSONNEL.
BECAUSE THE VARIABLE THAT
EFFECTS CASUALTY RATE IS THE
DURATION BETWEEN THE FIRST
GUN THAT IS UNHOLSTERRED AND
THE SECOND GUN THAT ARRIVES
TO STOP HIM IF IT INDEED
STOPS HIM OR ANY KIND OF
HARD TARGET.
>> Kimberly: THE RESPONSE
WEAPON.
>> Greg: THESE ARE TWO
THINGS THAT COME FROM TWO
AREAS.
ONE COMES FROM GUN CONTROL
WHEN WHICH IS A COURT THAT
PROVIDES A CIVIC TAG AND
THEN YOU ALSO HAVE ARMED
PERSONNEL WHICH IS WHAT
PEOPLE BELIEVE ENHANCES
FREEDOM AND SECURITY IS TO
HAVE SOMEBODY THERE WHO
KNOWS WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
THE THIRD THING, AS ALWAYS,
IS THE MEDIA.
AND THE MEDIA HAS TO BE
AWARE THAT BLANKET COVERAGE
CREATES INCENTIVE FOR MORE
OF THESE EVENTS BECAUSE IT
CREATES INFAMY.
AND THIS IS ABOUT INFAMY.
THIS IS NOT LIKE STREET
CRIME.
THIS IS THE TYPE OF CRIME
THAT IS SYMBOLIC NILISTIC
ACT THAT THE PERSON DOES SO
THEY CAN LIVE FOREVER.
AND IN OUR HEADS.
AND IT WORKS BECAUSE WE
CONSTANTLY DO BLANKET
COVERAGE.
SO IF WE HAVE TO LEARN HOW
TO PULL BACK FROM THIS AND
NOT TALK ABOUT THIS PERSON
AND NOT MENTION HIS NAME
BECAUSE WE'RE JUST GOING TO
CREATE MORE OF THEM.
IS HE TRENDING ON TWITTER.
>> Jesse: HE IS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE WERE ALARMED BY,
DANIEL, IS HE HAD THIS BIG
TRENCH COAT IN TEXAS, WHICH
IS VERY HOT.
PEOPLE SAID WHY ARE YOU
WEARING A TRENCH COAT?
>> Dana: APPARENTLY THOUGH,
I HAD OPPORTUNITY TO ANCHOR
THE HOURS WITH TRACE
GALLAGHER AND ONE OF THE
PEOPLE -- ONE OF THE
STUDENTS THAT WE INTERVIEWED
SHE SAID HE WORE THE TRENCH
COAT EVERY DAY.
WHAT WAS DIFFERENT TODAY WAS
THAT HE WORE A T-SHIRT UNDER
NEATH IT THAT SAID BORN TO
KILL.
>> Jesse: OH, GOD.
>> Dana: IT WAS INTERESTING
INTERVIEWING THOSE STUDENTS.
ALL THREE OF THEM WERE YOUNG
WOMEN.
THEY ARE SO POISED.
>> Jesse: ISN'T THAT
AMAZING.
>> Dana: MATURE AND
ARTICULATE AND ABLE TO PUT
THEIR THOUGHTS TOGETHER.
I THINK IT WAS VERY
DISTURBING AND PARENTS ALL
OF THEM SAID THEY WEREN'T
ENTIRELY SURPRISED.
THEY SORT OF EXPECTED THIS
MIGHT HAPPEN TO THEM
BECAUSE, AS GREG WAS JUST
SAYING WE COVER THEM AND IT
HAPPENS ALL TOO OFTEN OTHER
THING SIMILAR THEY HAD JUST
DONE FIRE DRILLS AND ACTIVE
SHOOTER DRILLS AT THIS
SCHOOL AND THEY HAD SOME
RESOURCES ACTUALLY THAT THEY
HAD TAKEN FROM THE STATE IN
ORDER TO GET THAT DONE.
I ASKED ONE OF THEM DO YOU
THINK IT HELPED TO SAVE
LIVES?
AND SHE SAID ABSOLUTELY
BECAUSE THEY KNEW WHAT TO DO
AND ONE OF THE TEACHERS, THE
BAND TEACHER WAS ACTUALLY
ABLE TO PUT THEM UP INTO A
ROOM THAT HAS A SOLID
CONCRETE WALL SO THAT NOBODY
CAN HEAR THE MUSIC BEING
PLAYED.
SO THAT TEACHER WAS VERY
QUICK-THINKING.
THE HOSPITAL HAD ALSO JUST
DONE A DRILL.
SO, THEY ARE LEVEL ONE
TRAUMA CENTER SO THEY WERE
ABLE TO SAVE LIVES VERY
QUICKLY.
GREG INMADE THIS POINT VERY
WELL BEFORE.
ON ALL ENDS, LAW
ENFORCEMENT, SCHOOLS AND THE
MEDICAL TEAMS, IN
PARTICULAR, MODERN MEDICINE
IS AMAZING BUT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE DONE THESE DRILLS, THEY
ARE ABLE TO SAVE A LOT MORE
LIVES MORE QUICKLY.
I ALSO WOULD POINT PEOPLE TO
LOOKING TO CHARLES COOK.
HE WRITES ON NATIONAL REVIEW
ABOUT THIS OBSESSION OF
COPYING THE COLUMBINE HIGH
SCHOOL SHOOTERS.
IT'S ALMOST TEXTBOOK.
AND YOU CAN GO THROUGH IT'S
VERY CHILLING WHEN YOU LOOK
AT IT AND BECOMES A LITTLE
BIT OF THE THING IF WE'RE
GOING TO BE IN THIS PRISON
OF TWO IDEAS WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE THIS FIGHT.
IN THE MEANTIME IT'S ALMOST
LIKE YOU DON'T KNOW HOW TO
STOP IT BECAUSE THEY ARE
ONLINE AND THEY ARE DOING
THIS.
THE ONLY POSSIBLE THING THAT
YOU COULD DO, MORE DRILLS
AND HARDENING OF TARGET.
CONGRESSMAN MICHAEL MCCAUL
FROM THAT DISTRICT.
THIS IS SUCH A SMALL WORLD
THING, JUST YESTERDAY HE
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD PROVIDE FOR GRANTS AND
MONEY FOR SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO TAKE ACTIONS AS
THEY SEE FIT BUT INCLUDING
CERTAINLY THESE TYPES OF
DRILLS.
AND THEN I SAID WOULD THAT
MONEY BE TIED TO ANYTHING IN
PARTICULAR?
HE SAID NO.
THE LAST ONE I WOULD MAKE IS
THAT LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
GAVE A PRESS CONFERENCE AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HE
SAID IS THAT THIS SHOOTER
TOOK THE GUN FROM THE
FATHER.
HE IS ONLY 17 YEARS OLD.
HE'S NOT SUPPOSED TO HAVE
THE GUN IN ANY WAY.
THEY JUST IMPLORED PARENTS
IF YOU HAVE WEAPONS THAT YOU
LEGALLY OWN, MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE LOCKED UP AND THAT
YOUR CHILDREN CAN'T GET
AHOLD OF THEM.
>> Jesse: THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT POINT.
THE WEAPONS HE USED A 38
REVOLVER AND A SHOTGUN.
RICHARD.
RICHARD:  I THINK DANA IS
RIGHT.
I PULLED A QUOTE FROM A
YOUNG WOMAN.
NO, THERE WASN'T.
IT'S BEEN HAPPENING ALL
OVER.
I HAVE ALWAYS KIND OF FELT
LIKE EVENTUALLY IT WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN HERE.
I WASN'T SURPRISED.
I WAS JUST SCARED.
AND AS I WATCHED HER
INTERVIEW AND AS I WAS
PREPARING FOR THE SHOW, THAT
QUOTE STUCK OUT TO ME
BECAUSE I THINK I'M ONE OF
THE YOUNGER FOLKS AT THIS
TABLE AND I WAS JUST LIKE I
LITERALLY GRADUATED FROM
COLLEGE 10 YEARS AGO, AND WE
NEVER HAD ACTIVE SHOOTER
TRAININGS WHEN I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND THAT WAS 14 YEARS
AGO.
AND TO THINK THAT THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE TODAY ARE
SAYING AT 17, LIKE I ALMOST
EXPECTED IT TO HAPPEN AT MY
SCHOOL.
AND SO WHEN IT HAPPENED, I
WASN'T SCARED.
TO ME, THIS IS SOMETHING HAS
GOT TO GIVE IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT WE HAVE GOT TO REALLY
DO EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER
AS ADULTS AND AS LAWMAKERS
AND AS PEOPLE OF INFLUENCE
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
SINGLE SCHOOL IN THIS
COUNTRY IS SAFE, WELCOMING,
AND THRIVING.
WE HAVE GOT TO MEET IN THE
MIDDLE.
PART OF IT IS HOW WE HARDEN
SOFT TARGETS AND THE OTHER
PART IS HOW WE RESTRICT
ACCESS TO GUNS.
RIGHT?
AND PART OF IT IS MAKING
SURE THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
GUNS ARE RESPONSIBLE AND
MAKING SURE IF YOU ARE A GUN
OWNER AND PARENT AND HAVE
YOU YOUNG PEOPLE IN YOUR
HOUSE, YOU LOCK THOSE GUNS
UP SO THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THEM.
>> Kimberly: AND MENTALLY
STABLE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND THE OTHER PART IS
FIXING, PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
IT HIMSELF, MAKING SURE WE
COMMIT TO FIXING THE
BACKGROUND SYSTEM.
>> Dana: IN THIS CASE IN
PARTICULAR.
>> IT WOULDN'T HAVE SOLVED
IT AND I THINK THE OTHER
THING THAT MAKES THIS EVEN
MORE SOBERING FOR ME IS THAT
THIS WEEKEND FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE IS GRADUATION
WEEKEND.
AND SO SOME -- AND A WE ARE
GOING TO HEAR MORE STORIES
AS WE GO INTO THIS WEEKEND
ABOUT SOME OF THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE AND I'M PRETTY SURE
SOME OF THEM SHOULD HAVE
BEEN WEARING A CAP AND GOWN
THIS WEEKEND AND THEY WON'T
BE.
>> Kimberly: REMEMBER THOSE
DAYS WHEN WE USED TO DO
EARTHQUAKE DRILLS THAT WAS
THE BIGGEST DANGER IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOR STUDENTS.